I know a lot of people here are going.
And the next question is about your tour. So Gagafame11 from the UK asks,...
"Do you have any funny stories to tell about things that have happened backstage at the Monster Ball?"
There are lots of funny things that happened backstage at the Monster Ball.
I don't like surprises and I don't like pranks.
I'm sure you can maybe tell that just from...
But I don't like pranks. But I actually, with me, have brought...
...all my friends from New York City on tour with me. So...
...I have had very few, I should say, famous acts opening. It's been mostly...
...really underground bands and DJs that I've known since I was 18 years old.
So there's a lot of backstage shenanigans.
Very often they make jokes about my diet 'cause they know I have to stay fit...
...for music videos, so they'll leave like mounds of cheese burgers and stuff in my dressing room.
It's really awful.
Vicious, vicious.